two weeks into a coveted lockdown in
china's biggest city the state
department has told all non-emergency
counselor staff to leave shanghai this
morning china's government relaxed the
shutdown in areas of shanghai that have
had no new covet cases some people were
allowed to leave their homes and some
food sellers were able to reopen it
appears the government's response to
public anger food shortages and a
serious business slowdown elizabeth
palmer has the very latest
it's the biggest urban coveted lockdown
in the world for more than two weeks
shanghai china's financial powerhouse
has been eerily quiet
the only bustle is at food depots where
there's a daily race to get groceries to
millions who aren't even allowed out to
shop billy stockton is one of them an
american working in shanghai he's been
confined to his apartment since late
march no one knows where to get stuff no
one knows where to get medical help and
it's creating panic and fear
and just instability
like the angry protests in areas where
food actually ran out in this one the
crowd is shouting we are starving
small groups of residents have been
allowed out but only briefly for coveted
testing and positive cases had no choice
as one patient posted on tick tock they
had to board a special bus and check in
to a government isolation center which
is clearly ready for an onslaught of new
cases
at the same time authorities are
releasing old cases now testing negative
but this is false freedom the 6 000
people let go on monday headed straight
back into lockdown at home
in the last 24 hours the government
announced people in some covid free
neighborhoods would be getting real
freedom
but looking out of billy stockton's
window there's no sign of that and only
murky details on when it might happen
meanwhile billy's been taking stock of
his dwindling food supply so what are
you going to have for
supper i have um sausages and then they
supplied a bag of rice yesterday
so simple stuff like that do you feel as
if you're trapped in a bit of a
nightmare
it's beyond surreal it's just like you
kind of have to pull yourself mentally
out of it to get through it
but getting through it could take
another couple of weeks
the question is whether there's going to
be any lasting fallout among shanghai
residents who have rarely if ever felt
so abused and mistreated by their
government
for cbs mornings elizabeth palmer tokyo
boy that is a really interesting
question i mean there's political
fallout and pushback over masked
mandates in philadelphia and other
places in this country and you've got a
six-lane highway with no cars on it like
two o'clock in the afternoon there in
shanghai wow i've seen video of people
from their apartment buildings at night
you know shouting in frustration
shouting that they're starving in
shanghai because they're locked into
their homes why are they so extreme
there do they know something we don't
know isn't it that's what i was trying
to make a little worried i'd also like
to know the type of vaccines that they
have there right the vaccination oh and
the vaccination rate and the rate yeah
of people who are vaccinated i sure hope
i hope it's not a sign of things to come
here i don't think we'd ever be locked
in our homes but i just don't want to be
locked down at all no no no no happen
here uh all right coming up is it time
for flying to go back to normal we'll
show you why airlines say we should not
have to wear masks on a plane even
though new coveted infections are going
up we were just talking about that right
but first it is 7
17 right on the dot time to check your
local weather
[Music]
you